honk about Nell you are a member of
Nobel Committee for physics and this
year's price is about neutrinos replace
the prize for exactly so this year the
prize honors a fundamental discovery in
physics and since neutrinos are very
common in our surroundings and they have
very common particles in the universe
the discovery that neutrinos actually
not massless makes a difference it makes
a difference theoretically but it also
makes the difference to how our son
functions if it wouldn't be for
neutrinos the Sun would not be shining
anymore if it wouldn't be for neutrinos
supernovas would not be exploding the
way they explode the elements that we
all made of would not exist so neutrinos
are very important but this is
fundamental physics what are neutrinos
then well I wish we knew what neutrinos
are neutrinos are among these few
fundamental particles which make up
matter and we know them from radioactive
decays but what they really are no one
knows no one has ever seen a neutrino
neutrinos have no electric charge and we
can only detect particles which carry
electric charge and so we can only
discover neutrinos when they interact
with something and produce charged
particles and this is how we know there
are three kinds of neutrinos but no one
has ever seen the neutrino itself and
the price is actually for discovery of
neutrinos oscillations the neutrinos
change identities also
what does it mean well it means that new
chinos it's very hard to say that the
new Trina changes identity because it
makes you think of the fact that you
know you have a neutrino sitting on the
table in front of you and over all over
suddenly become something else so
neutrinos do not change identity like
that they change identity while they
move through space when they do that you
can produce one kind of neutrino but
then if you try to detect it 100
hundreds of kilometers further way you
discover that what you catch it's not
the same kind of neutrino but a
different type in Chino so something has
happened on the way from the source to
the detector and this is what we call
neutrino oscillations and this has to do
with quantum mechanics and quantum
mechanics I can see that you know as
soon as you say quantum mechanics people
get totally you know this is not for me
I don't want you know I'm not going to
understand it but in reality it's not
that difficult quantum mechanics
describes particles moving through space
like waves so if you think of waves in a
pond like someone throwing two stones in
a pond both stones we create waves and
his waves will interfere and likewise in
space neutrinos moving in space I
described by waves these ways interfere
they overlap and this is what we
discover in the form of solutions so
isn't it's an interpretation of a
quantum mechanical phenomenon and the
two lauritz this year they made big
experiments
big collaborations how come these two
scientists were awarded this price so it
is true that these two scientists a part
of the collaborations we have the
Sudbury neutrino Observatory
collaboration headed by art McDonald
since 1990 art was one of the 16 people
who proposed Sudbury neutrino
Observatory back in 1994 so he has
really been in the journey from the very
beginning he has made a proposal he has
built the observatory he has been the
organizational and intellectual leader
of this venture on the other side we
have this super-kamiokande observatory
in a mine in Japan super-kamiokande
works somewhat different
super-kamiokande is a second generation
observatory following the cam you convey
tecate cajita worked on cameo candy
while a PhD student and he worked with
atmospheric neutrinos we're moving to
super-kamiokande he led one of the three
experimental groups trying to make sense
of the data they were getting so he was
leading the atmospheric nacino group and
tried to investigate the properties of
the neutrinos so he was the intellectual
leader of this effort and both my
discoveries around the turn of this
millennium
you mentioned that neutrinos still are a
big puzzle so what's going on since then
so since then we'll discover that
neutrinos are even more of a challenge
than we thought they were because ok if
neutrinos are massless we do not
understand it but at least the mass
identical to zero is one of the
fundamental constants of the universe
and just describes the universe we live
in now we know that machino mass is not
zero so now the question becomes why is
it not zero and why is it so small so if
we if we physicist discover something
which is very small but actually not
equal to 0 we get very excited because
there must be something which makes this
quantity small but not zero there's a
lot of experimental activity one trying
to determine exactly what the mass is we
don't know what the mass is we only know
an upper limit we want to know why the
mass is so small and of course theorists
have lots of proposals we want to know
why neutrinos only appear in a
left-handed variety and not in the
right-handed variety they may be a new
type of particle just got the mayor on a
particle so people are trying to figure
out that and so you know in the end this
discovery of neutrino oscillations has
created a wide open field so instead of
just trying to determine what the
neutrino mass is we are not trying to
determine the properties of the machine
oh and this may teach us a whole lot of
new things about the universe
you yourself are a spokesperson for the
big experiment on this cell phone can
you tell us about neutrinos yeah Emma's
I always love to tell about moschino of
the South Pole yeah I'm the spokesperson
of the international ice cream
collaboration so we are about 300
scientists working with the detective
buried deep underground will be low the
surface of Antarctica at the South Pole
there is a detector in the glacier
detecting not atmospheric and not solar
neutrinos but we hope to see neutrinos
coming from the outer space we do to
take atmospheric moschino but to us this
is not a signal it's a calibration
source so since we since that theories
describing how the atmosphere functions
we use the atmospheric neutrinos to
calibrate our detector however a few
years ago in 2013 we discovered the
flocks from the outer space neutrinos
coming not from our galaxy but somewhere
from the outside of our galaxy and this
is at first and for this discovery I
skip was named the breakthrough of the
year 2013 and now we are continuing on
this path and try to learn more about
these cosmic neutrinos which sources
produced them and how they get these
enormous energies which are millions of
times larger than what the Sun is
capable of doing and what we can do with
our man-made terrestrial accelerators so
once more there is a lot of experiments
about neutrinos they are going on why is
it so important to know just
neutrinos what they are well this is an
important question and this year's prize
is for fundamental physics definitely
now the use of fundamental physics for
society something I could discuss at
length but it's clear that humans have
this urge to learn more about the
universe that we live in and fundamental
science is one of the pillars of modern
society so I usually say that if we
didn't have this urge you would still be
living in caves and we would still be
afraid of the lightning but having
learned what we have we have built a
modern society with computers with gps
with cures for cancer all these things
are Bay's of on discoveries in
fundamental science Einstein didn't
develop the special relativity to give
us GPS but we have GPS and it's pays a
lot of is special but of these general
theory of relativity we are still
curious yeah thank you very much volga
boatmen